[Music]
Holloway went old gold blam last night
at the world famous Chinese Theatre with
Susan's Brandon and Jessica Lange posing
beside vintage automobiles and it was
all for the mirror of a classic
Hollywood story feud Betty and Jones
yeah this is the stuff of legend I mean
Betty Davis versus Joan Crawford and we
get two icons playing two icons doesn't
get much better than that how big was
this feud between Betty Davis and Joan
Crawford I think there was a great deal
of competition and I don't think they
necessarily liked each other that's
Jessica Lange who plays Joan Crawford
she can't be serious
Susan Sarandon is Betty Davis I'm gonna
steal this picture right out from under
your nose then you know I can do it
feud follows the actresses in their
later years during the making of the
1962 film whatever happened to Baby Jane
oh oh oh God she did that on purpose I
barely touched it but flashbacks help
answer the question what caused this
epic feud one factor the legendary
actresses fought for the same roles I
think had the studio not pitted them
against each other and had things gone
more smoothly in terms of the production
probably they would have been all right
Davis added to all the few talk when she
was quoted as saying miss Crawford is a
movie star and I am an actress I am just
too much
et sat down with Davis several times in
the 80s and you could see just how hard
she fought for a good role I am praying
on my knees every day to get a good
script you must never give up never give
up competition aside there was another
issue
Crawford's brief marriage to act your
friend show tone weren't they in love
with the same man well yes I mean there
was the the you know the history with
French otome because I think Betty fell
in love with him but he was in love with
Joan and then there were stories of
dirty tricks in this scene from Baby
Jane legend has it Joan wore a weight
belt to make it more difficult for Betty
to drag her across the floor all of this
made us
wonder how Betty might have reacted to
her portrayal well here's what she told
et about dealing with bad press 35 years
ago we all want to be liked but that's
part of the the training of a Hollywood
career you're going to have terrible
things said about and my mother was
always wonderful about this she used to
say to me daddy do not forget it's the
best fruit the birds ticket which is a
wonderful thing to remember
[Music]